hi okay let me get started for today uh I guess I'm now down to the the more select week eight audience of people who actually want to learn so uh my welcome and my pleasure for the people who show up today thank you thank you um okay so what I want to do today um is Prince ibly sort of talk about a couple of other newal network techniques which can be used for language I mean in some sense um these two techniques are G ones that people aren't using very much these days and that's partly why they get sort
of stuck towards the end of the course um because we try to teach people early on in the course um the most essential things that you should definitely know about um but you know um the fact of the matter is you know in any scientific field there are different ideas and techniques that bounce around and it's good to know a few of the different ideas that are out there because often what happens is people find new ways to reinvent things um and put things together and see different insides from
them so today I'm going to tell you a little bit about using convolutional new networks for language Edge and then a bit about tree recursive neural networks um but before that um just course organization um this is a a bit after it happened but I guess I've never been back to say it so thanks to everyone who filled in the mid quarter surveys um some people said very nice things about the lecture fantastic lectures and really interesting content um some people uh wished that we were teaching more about State space models I
guess we haven't added those that lecture in yet um um a couple of people thought it' be good to have an exam in this class clearly they weren't people who have friends in cs231n from what I've heard but um um yeah uh and then um in general people are pretty happy how Ed has been going uh a bit less happy on how office hours have been going I mean honestly it's a hard problem I feel to do office hours you know some people are saying oh you should just use Q status I sort of remember badly to a year where
we did everything but Q status and near the assignments due date the the C would stretch six hours long and that didn't seem such a good solution either um but we'll work along with it um finally yeah on on cloud compute I know this is something that people variously do have issues with so um there are quite a few people that still trying to do things with Google collab um which I realize is sort of a very convenient nice interface but you sort of do suffer from access to gpus um on Google collab the best way to
get better access to gpus is to pay 10 bucks for a month of collab Pro um which perhaps means that you end up paying for two months um for if it's May and June um we can't reimburse you for that um but not so many copies worth of money and it does just give you better access to gpus I'm encourage you to use the gcp credits and together AP API access that we've given to you um you're also welcome to try other things kaggle notebooks can actually give you be better GPU access but um not as not all
the nice features of collabs um some groups have started using modal which is can also be um a good way to get GPU access okay that was the intro to that um and so now I wanted to just sort of talk about convolutional new networks um for language I mean these slides are sort of positioned a bit as convolutional new networks versus rnns as opposed to versus Transformers I mean that's um partly you could say because I haven't updated my slides enough but in another sense that's partly because
that's how the ideas of convolutional neural networks really were explored it was in the days when most people were using recursive neural networks for NLP a few people said about saying hey maybe we should use convolutional newal networks for language as well um whereas in truth in The Last 5 Years when Transformers have dominated there hasn't been much use of convolutional neural networks for NLP um so if we think back to our new networks um if you remember those that they kind of gave a way of
giving a representation um for a sentence or part of a sentence but they sort of computed forward through the string um and so you kind of had to get a representation that included in everything that came before you and then you so um you didn't really have a representation of the ceremony you had a representation of man walked into the ceremony that you could use um so in contrast to that convolutional neural networks basically say well you know kind of like an engr model that we should be able to take
engrams of words like two G or three G so for the example tentative deal reach to keep the government open that we can take each Three G tentative deal reach deal reach to reach to keep keep government and we can make uh some neural representation for each of those so notice just being done for every um engram for a certain end so there's nothing linguistically or cognitively especially plausible here um but we're just going to sort of form representations of multi-word units which will'll then group in some form
further way later on and the standard way of doing that is with convol convolutional neural networks um so the classic case of convolutional neuron networks is in Vision um the convolutional neuron networks were invented for vision where they gave you a kind of a translation invariant um model so that you could recognize your kangaroo no matter where in the frame it was and so this little picture here which I'll just do the lower half side of SL lower half of the slide is sort of the what a
convolutional new network is doing in 2D video so the convolution is like a mask that you're sliding over the image and the mask is defined by weights which are the little things shown in red and so for each place you slide your masks to you're then calculating a score by taking well what's effectively a DOT product of the Mask terms by the elements in that patch and that's then filling in The Matrix on the right um that's shown in pink and so that's then calculating our convolved feature um
from the image uh that make sense yeah so well what happens if we then want to do that for language well you know for language we don't have a 2d picture we've got a 1D picture we've got a sequence of words so we can have tentative deal reach to keep government open so each of our words will have a word Vector I'm using four-dimensional in my examples to keep it compact on my slide and so then we can apply um a filter that applies to an engr so this is going to be a filter for trigram and
so then we're going to slide that downwards in the exactly the same way as for the vision case apart from we're just sliding in one dimension so I calculate um the dot product of the filter and this three G and that gives me a value minus one if I did my arithmetic right then I slide it down to the next position and work it out and I get minus 0.5 um slide it down get the other values and then typically I can add on a bias term so my bias is plus one in this example and then I'll stick it through a
nonlinearity like a sigmoid or something like that and so I'll be calculating a vector for a term for each um of these three GRS and so that is a convolution for a single filter um and then commonly what I'm doing after that is deciding that I'm going to have more than one filter and I'll show that in a minute um in this example um and in my vision example earlier we sort of had shrinkage because we started off with seven words but course we sort of slid these um you know trigram over it we only sort
of had space for um five trigrams and so we ended up with something smaller than our input sentence often people want to keep it the same size and the way you can keep it the same size is by having padding so if I put a a zero padding at each end well now I'm going to get seven trigrams coming out as corresponding to my original seven words and normally I'll just sort of pad it with zeros like that um you can actually increase the size of things because if you add um padding of two at each end you can then
have a wide convolution and so seven will then go to nine different things okay so if we only had one filter things are pretty limiting and so commonly as in the vision case what we're going to do is um Define multiple filters and then we're going to be calculating a value for each of these filters over each of these triag and so then we're getting out a new representation as a vector and you know depending on how many filters we have relative to what the word dimensionality is we might end up with something that's
shorter as in this example the same length or actually longer than what our input was in terms of word vectors um but commonly um when we do that um we then in some way want to summarize all of these filters and the most common way of doing that is to do something that's called Max pooling and Max pooling is something you see quite a bit in newal networks in general and the way to think of Max pooling that I think makes sense is that you can think of um max pooling is doing what you want if you R want to
run something that's like a feature detector so you know if you imagine that you'd you learn these functions um that will look at word vectors and that they will look for evidence of something particular so you know maybe this filter looks for the person is using I language that it's matches the words I my we our something like this and you know maybe this is a filter that matches you know speech verbs like or thinking verbs like think say um said told Etc like that um and so each of these is sort of some
kind of feature of the text that you might want to detect well if that's your model of it when you sort of slide your feature detector down the piece of text you sort of want to know does this match anywhere in this piece of text is somewhere at using an i word regardless of whether it's in the first second third or fourth position and so that's effectively what you're getting out with Max pooling that a feature is counting as firing to the extent that it fires strongly in any position in the text
that you could match um that's not the only way you can think of doing it an alternative way you could do it is you could think of your featured tector as sort of measuring some quality of the text like um casualness or learnedness or something like that and then you might think oh well for overall wanting to know how casual the text is maybe I want to know the average of how casual it is in different parts of the text and so then you can do the alternative of average pooling and sometimes people do
that as well you can do both you can both work out an average pull and a Max pull and put both of them into the feature detector in general for the kind of features people learn in your networks if you're just doing one or the other the result does seem to be that Max pooling is the most effective that that kind of does the feature fire metaphor tends in general um to be um the best way of thinking about things okay so if you want to do all of this in pytorch um con 1D right so um that guess the one-dimensional
convolutions aren't the most common case and so you're using com 1D and all these kind of things that you can then be specifying so the output channels is the number of filters you have the kernel size is saying the size is how big it is which for my example was three um and then you can sort of just collapse things with the max pulling okay um there's a space of other things that you can also do with convolutional newal networks which I think are sort of less useful and less used and language cases but I can sort
of say them quickly so one thing you can do um is sort of have a stride CU When we sort of did every trigram of sort of zero tentative deal then tentative deal reach then deal reach 2 you could feel like well they're overlapping each other a lot so they've actually got very similar stuff in them and that would be even more so if we weren't using 3 G we were using something like five G so something that you can do is the stride is sort of how much you move along so if you move along two you'd have one trigram that's um
padding tentative deal and then the next one would then be deal reach two and then the next one would be to keep government so that they're overlapping by less as you go through it um another thing that you can then do um that's sort of stride like is rather than um doing Max pulling over the entire thing you could do more of a local Max pull so um you could think that well I want to have this feature detector for something like use of eye language but you know if it's a big long sentence and there's eye language at
four different points points maybe you should get four points for that rather than just sort of the one point that you're going to get from Max pulling so you could sort of do local Max pulling sensitive to the stride so here I could look at the first two of these and Max pull those two then the next two and Max pull those the next two and Max pull those and the next pull two and Max pull those and you could sort of then end up with this sort of local Max pooling as you go along um okay um and then one other idea
that's sort of related um that you can um do is well another way of capturing sort of does something match in multiple places is rather than only keeping the One Max in each column maybe you could just do a k Max so you could keep the two maximum things in a column and that might be also be a way of seeing whether something is detected in two places or not um okay um then I've got lots of Notions here okay so um dilation is then the notion um that what we'd like to do is sort of form our
trigrams not only as adjacent things but things that are spaced out so after having done our first layer of convolutional filters that took trigrams that got us to the sort of top right part here we could then do a dilated trigram convolution which means that we're going to take the first third and fifth things and um combine them in a convolutional filter and then we'll take the second fourth and six things and combine them in a um convolutional filter and so we've then got a trigram
filter but it sort of has a bigger range of size that it can see um and that's sometimes used more commonly used in places like speech than a natural language okay so those are the kind of tools we have um for calculating things with these convolutions over text and so next what I want to do you do is tell you about a a couple of pieces of work that made use of convolutions natural language processing I guess this is a decade old now because this is from 2014 um this is um the single most famous piece of work that made use of
convolutional neural networks for natural language processing um and Yun Kim is now an assistant professor at MIT I mean in retrospect it's sort of actually pretty simple um but I guess you know he got in early with the idea of okay maybe um we could use convolutions um for NLP and did a kind of a clear example of that that worked pretty well um and so this piece of work is very well known um so this was um writing a sentiment classifier so looking at a sentence and deciding whether it's um positive or negative and
actually for both the kind of models that I'm going to talk about today we're going to use examples um that are doing sentiments classification he also considered other tasks subjective or objective language question classification as to what they were about but the main application was doing sentiment analysis so what you're going to be doing um this this paper shows things more in his notation but it's exactly the same as we've just been talking about that you're taking engrams of word
vectors you're going to be um multiplying them by convolution and calculating new vectors and it's going to be done in his model for different sizes of NR so he's going to have some convolutional filters that look at byrs some at Tri and some of them that look at forrs and then those just slid across the positions in the sentence um then having done that it does Max pooling as we've been talking about which gives a single number um coming out of each filter and those Max pulled numbers from each filter and then going
to be used as a classifier in a final simple softmax layer to give the full answers um there's one other thing that came up in this paper which is kind of just an interesting general idea um to be aware of um and it was something he sort of pioneered which is the following that it's a very common case um that what you for when you're sort of this I guess this again occurs less with huge pre-trained Transformers but for sort of the classic case of models where you had word vectors and then you were training
some neural network model um on some supervised data um there was this following Pitfall of what happened when you fine-tuned word vectors and so the setting is you know we've started off with um our pre-trained word vectors from glove or word to V or whatever it is and then we've got a smaller um sentiment analysis data set and that we're going to um train a sentiment classifier and that will involve not only um learning the parameters of our sentiment classifier but also we can back propop into the word Vector
representations um and if you do that I mean it seems like that should be a good idea because you know normal word vectors aren't you know especially tuned to predicting sentiment correctly um they're sort of more tuned to meaning of words as to sort of um just what words are about and so it seems like it should help you if you could um back propop into the word vectors and change them as you go along but if you do that there tends to be a problem and the problem is um what you'll find is that some words will be
in your sentiment training data set and when you um learn um with backprop these word vectors will move but some words just won't be in your trading data and they're going to stay exactly where they were in the word de vectors because there's nothing to move them around so what tends to happen is you sort of started off like this where all of tedious dull and plotting were close by each other as having similar meanings and the indicators of something negative but after you done your training um
tedious and dull as part of back propop have moved over here where they're part of the um negative land and the classification boundaries moved over here but plotting wasn't in the training set so it's just sitting exactly where it was at the start of the process and now it's being treated as a positive word which is completely wrong and so that's tended to have the result that um when people sort of train uh Language new network on a small supervised data set you got kind of ambivalent results
that sometimes um doing back prop into the word vectors would help because you could specialize your word vectors to your task but sometimes it would hurt you because of this kind of effect that you sort of messed up the semantic relations that applied over the that were captured reasonably well in the initial word vectors um so the way that um Yun Kim dealt with that was a fairly um simple way um he just doubled his number of channels and so he made two copies of each um Channel each filter in his convolutional neural
network and for one of them it used the fine-tuned word vectors and for one of them it kept the original word vectors and then he could have the best of both worlds okay um so this picture um captures the sort of whole of um his Network um this picture actually comes on from comes from a followon paper which produced this nice picture so we start off with a sentence I like this movie very much which should be classified positive um so we have words and their word vectors and so then you're going to have convolutional field
filters that are both byr filters trigr filters and forr filters and at each of those sizes you're going to have ones that work on the unfin tuned word vectors and the fine-tuned word vectors um and so you're going to put these filters and slide them over the text and get um representations and the way he's doing this the filters are done without padding so that the 4 gr filters you're getting smaller vectors coming out um and the byr filters you've got bigger vectors coming out and so then for each
of these you're then going to Max pull um so you're just getting the highest value from it and then you're getting a highest value from the ones with um the fine tuning of the word vectors and the ones not and so you're getting one one feature out of each filter you're then concatenating all of those Max pulled outputs together so then one vector for the entire sentence which is of fixed size reflecting the number of filters um and then you're just sticking this as a straightforward um linear classifier
into a soft Max that's then giving you a probability of a positive or negative and that was the entire model um and the interesting thing was this actually worked pretty well um for natural language classification tasks so um this is a big table of results from his paper so um there are sentiment data sets like the Stanford sentiment Tree Bank two versions of that um movie reviews there's another sentiment data set there's a subjectivity classifier um the Tre was the kind of question type classifier um so various
data sets um and um that you know various people um including us at Stanford I guess all of these soed hour results were ones we were doing at Stanford um had built um lots of models on various of these data sets and his argument was that by using this simple convolutional new network um you could do as as well sometimes better than any of these other models that were being considered at the time for sentiment analysis now there was at least one way in which um maybe that comparison was too generous to the CNN so um because um
if you remember back when we um were doing Dropout and we said Dropout is such a good idea I mean Dropout I think came out in 2012 if I'm remember remembering correctly so the reality is a lot of these other methods were being written before Dropout appeared on the scene whereas he was using Dropout and that gave him an advantage and sort of better experimental technique might have been to compare to redo the other models with Dropout um um which he didn't um but nevertheless it sort of shows that
you could get strong results using convolutional newal networks um with just a very simple architecture yeah um so that's one more thing that you can do and so I mean the thing to think about here is you know we have this sort of toolkit of ways that you can do things we started off with um word vectors and bags of vectors which you could use for simple classification we talked early on about window models and your window models are sort of like what you get for convolutional your network works but sort of more ad hoc um
then we have convolutional newal networks which are definitely good for classification and very easy to paralyze which is good and we talked about recurrent newal networks which seem to be cognitively plausible reading through sentences from left to right but aren't easy to parallelize um and then we've talked about Transformers um which to some extent is our you know best model for NLP and is being used everywhere and indeed you know what's happening now is that things are going in reverse and people are
increasingly using Transformers for vision as well though there's still I think more debate in The Vision World as between CNN and Transformers with some people arguing that both of them have complimentary advantages okay um couple of other just facts on the side and then I'll um show you um one other um bigger fancier convolutional new network model for language um so we talked about for Transformer models the use of layer normalization which sort of um keeps the size of the numbers in the middle layers
of the newal network about the Same by giving zero mean and um unit variance um there are slightly different ways that you can do that um for tional new networks the standard thing to be using is batch normalization and indeed batch normalization was the thing that was invented first and sort of layer normalization and batch normalization are sort of doing the same thing of sort of scaling numbers to give them zero mean and unit variance but the way that they differ is sort of under what dimensions they're doing their
calculations um so that layer Norm is calculating statistics across the feature Dimension whereas batch Norm is normalizing all the elements in the batch for each um feature independently okay one other little concept that turns up um which actually sort of connects a bit to Transformers as well there's this sort of funny thing that you can all of what I've presented so far was sort of volutions that are some INR byr Tri for GR and so they're also size one convolutions and at first sight that
seems to make no sense at all cuz what's the point of doing a size one convolution because you just got one thing and it's staying just one thing but it actually does make sense because it corresponds to having a little fully connected layer that's only looking at the representation in one position so in a language term is taking a word vector and putting it through a fully connected neural network to produce a new representation just of that word and that's sort of actually what we also
have with the fully connected layers and Transformers right that you've got a fully connected layer that's just at one well subword token position and calculates a new representation for it um and so that's um allows you to sort of create new representations with actually many fewer parameters than if you're allowing a fully connected layer across the entire sentence okay and so this is then a more recent version of a convolutional newal network still again used for text classification but a much more complex
one um from Cano Al in 2017 um and again this was still at the stage um in which lstm sequence models were dominant in NLP I guess in 2017 this is sort of the same year the first Transformer paper um came out and you know there were the motivations were sort of comparing vision and language um and so at that point in time um convolutional new network models and vision were already very deep models so people were using things like resnet models that had 30 50 100 layers in them and that stood in um stark contrast to
what was happening in the lstm world for sequence models where commonly people were just using two layer sequence models and if you're wanting to go further you might be using a thre layer sequence model or four layer sequence model or occasionally if you got really really deep um people had used eight layer sequence models if they had a lot of data but essentially you know it was always in a single digit the number of layers um and then a second thing was you know in some sense the vision models
were more raw signal models because they were operating on the individual pixel level whereas in NLP the standard was that we were using Word level models still in the Transformer model so it sort of seemed like things were much more grouped before they began and so the idea of this paper is well maybe we could do NLP kind of like it was Vision so we'll start with the raw characters as our signal we're going to put them into a deeper convolutional neural network work and use the same kind of
architecture um we use for vision and use that for language classification tasks and so that um led to this VD CNN architecture which is something um that looks very like a vision system in design um and so what do we have here so at the bottom um we have um individual characters um and the individual characters get a 16d representation um and then you've got some sort of size of piece of text that you're classifying um which for them was 1,24 um and then at each stage we're then going to have convolutional blocks
um and so these convolutional blocks um have a whole bunch of filters but they're also then going to group stuff together um so that we're kind of sort of starting to collapse into multicar units um so we're starting off first of all having you know 64 um size three um convolutional filters um and so that gives us a representation of 64 um times the window size um and then then um we're going to do that again and put it um through another set of convolutional filters of size three and 64 of them
which gets us sort of up to here um and then at each point we also have residual connections which we also saw in Transformers but were pioneered in the vision space so that we have a path that things can just go straight through but then when we get to here um we then then going to do local pooling so each pair of representations here will be pulled together and so at that point we've no longer got a length of the initial length of 1,24 we've now got a a length of um 512 um so now we're going to be putting
it through again sort of trigram convolutions but now we're going to have 128 of those channels um we're going to repeat that again and then we're going to again group with pooling so now we're going to um have 256 um long sequence because we've done local pooling of each pair um and we're going to then have 256 filters at each stage and we go up and then we do local pulling again so each of them is now representing an eight G of characters um and we're putting triam filters over
those 8 G so really the amount of a sentence that the convolutional filters is seeing at this point is 24 characters so you know sort of seeing something like six-word sequences or something like that more convolutional blocks there um then at there they then do this ke KX pooling so some of the ideas from the beginning of the lecture um do show up so you're then doing kmax pooling and finding the eight highest activations in the sequence and that sort of makes sense for something like a text
classifier because you want to count up the amount of evidence right if you got some category like is this about I don't know uh copper mining you want to be seeing whether there's a bunch of places in the Tex that's talking about copper mining um and then right up the top they have several fully connected layers which again is very typical of what you are finding in Vision networks um such as something like vggnet um that after you've done a whole bunch of um convolutional layers You' just stick it
through multiple fully connected layers at the top and so that's what they're doing as well and this is your architecture um for doing text in um okay I think I talked through that in a lot of detail um so I'll skip this slide um yeah so um their experiments were done on text classification data sets so um various news classification data sets um dbpedia onology um then doing sentiment analysis on Yelp reviews and Amazon reviews um and here here um results um from their one so you know they're
taking the previous known best published results which are shown here in table four and then they're considering whether they can do better by using their architecture and that they um used architectures of different lengths in terms of the number of um layers of nine layers 17 and 29 layers and the result of the paper is in all cases um they got the best results by their deepest Network which was a 29 layer model which is sort of then sort of similar to what people were doing in Vision um and then you know there's some
variation as to which was best by using the max pulling or the kmax pulling but in general was always the Deep model and it varied a bit according to the data set but at least sometimes they were able to produce the best results that were known so I mean I guess for these text classification previous results were slightly better than their results um but for some of the other ones like the DBP and the Yelp that their results uh or Al well for both the Yelp data sets their results were better than the best
known previous results um the Amazon ones one was better one was worse but to a first approximation this meant that they could basically reach the state-ofthe-art of a text classification system with something that was just a deep convolutional neural network starting from the character level with none of the sort of Having learned word vectors in advance or anything like that and so that was a pretty cool achievement which showed that you could go a Fair Way um in doing things um with just this sort of raw character level
convolutional new networks sort of more like a vision system okay so that's that and then for the final piece of the class I then want to tell tell you about something in The Other Extreme um which is about um tree recursive neural networks so tree recursive neural networks is a framework um that me and students developed at Stanford so I mean really um when I first got into new network day in 2010 that sort of for about the first five years um that what me and students worked on was doing these tree recursive
newal networks and so they were sort of um the Stanford brand um ultimately um they didn't prove as successful as other things that came along but I think they're linguistically interested in and I think there's a clear idea here which is still an idea that exists and um I think there may be still some things to do with which I'll come back to but the starting point is essentially being motivated by structure of human language um and so most of this slide is sort of filled um by a paper
from gome Chomsky and colleagues sort of discussing um their views of the human faculty of language what it is who has and how did it evolve um and I don't uh want to dwell on this in too much detail but essentially in this paper what they argue is that you know the defining property of human language um that's not observed in other things that humans do is having that language has this recursive structure that you have this hierarchical nesting where the same structure repeats inside itself so if
you have an example um like the person standing next to the man from the company that purchased the firm that you used to work at um what you have is um you the whole of this is a noun phrase the person headed by the person and then it's standing next to then the first square brackets here is another noun phrase the man from then inside that prepositional phrase there's another noun phrase the company that purchased um the firm and then the firm is another noun phrase that has the uh relative Clause modifier of the firm
that you used to work at so we have these embedded layers of noun phrases with the same syntactic structure underneath them and so for the kind of formalisms that we use in linguistics of context free grammar we they it permits the kind of infinite embedding of nesting which is the same kind of nesting that you get in programming languages where you can sort of use if statements and Nest them as deeply as you want to because you just have the same repeating recursive structure now of course human beings can't actually
understand recursive infinite recursion and people don't actually produce infinite recursion that you could sort of say oh in practice no one's going to go more than eight deep when they're saying a sentence but in terms of the structure of what the language looks like it seems like you should be able to do it infinitely deep and when you actually start looking at the structures of sentences um they do sort of repeat over the same structure quite deeply so this is uh example of a pen Tree Bank um
tree which is sort of the best known um constituency um tree bank and so here's my random sentence analyst said Mr stronck wants to resume assum a more influential role in running the company and well what we end up with sort of if we have these nested things of verb phrases so running the company is a verb phrase resume a more influential role in running the company is a bigger verb phrase um wants to resume a bigger role in running the company as an even bigger verb phrase and then said Mr stronck
wants to resume a more influential role in running the company is an even bigger verb phrase and so we have sort of one 2 three four verb phrases all nested inside each other and so the idea was well maybe we should be thinking of sentences as having this kind of tree structure and Computing representations of meanings of sentences in terms of this tree structure so um we have words that have representations in uh word Vector space like we saw right at the beginning of the class but then we're going to have a
phrase like the country of my birth and the classic linguistic answer that you find both in linguistic semantics classes or philosophy of language is that we could should construct representations of phrases using the principle of compositionality which says that the meaning of a phrase or sentence is determined by the meanings of its Words which are our word vectors and the rules that combine them so maybe we could take the phrase structure tree of a sentence and combine the word vectors together by some means and then we can
construct a representation of the meaning of phrases in a more linguistic way giving us a vector representation of the meaning of the phrase which we could also put into our Vector space and we'd hope that a phrase like the country of my birth would appear in the vector space in a similar place to where words representing locations appeared okay so what we want is to be able to start with word vectors and Pa up a sentence and as we pause the sentence we're then going to be Computing representations for the different
phrases of the sentence um and so the difference here is now you know um you know the difference between recursive and recurrent is sort of a fake difference right they both come from the same recur word um but rather than having the recursion Just Happening along a sequence as in a recurrent newal Network we're going to have the recursion happening uper tree structure so we can Computing representations for linguistically Meaningful phrases um and so there sort of um what we're going to do with that is you know
the easy Cas is if we know um the phrase structure tree we can take the representations of the child nodes put them into a neural network which could give us the representation of the parent node but we'd also like to find the tree structure and so a way we could do that is then get a second thing out of the newal network we could get a score for how plausible something is as a constituent does it make sense to combine these two nose together to form a larger constituent and then we can use
that in AA so um formerly the very simplest kind of tral network and the first one we explored was when we had two child vectors we're going to be um representing the parent vector by concatenating the two children multiplying them by a matrix adding a bias putting it through a nonlinearity to get a parent representation p and then we'd score whether it's a good constituent by taking another um Vector of learn parameters which would um do a DOT product with p and that would give us a score as to whether this was a good
constituent to include in your past tree and the same W parameters were used at all nodes of the tree in the same way as a new a current new network kept using the same parameters okay um so if we did that if we had that we could build a greedy paa cuz what we could do is we could start with all the word vectors and we could just take every pair of words and put it through this system and calculate what the representation of that pair would be as a constituent and then get a score as to whether it seemed a good constituent
or not and then we could just greedily decide this is the best constituent the cat and so if we do a greedy paraa we can commit to that and then well we already still know the the possibilities of combining other pairs of words and we could just additionally um score how good um the the cat combined with sat is um so that we producing binary um PA structures so now the best pair to combine greedily is the mat so we can combine them together and commit to those we can score combining on with the m that and now that seems
the best thing so we'll commit to that and we just sort of keep on up and we produce the binary pars of the sentence and this gives us our sentence representation okay which is like that okay and so that gives us our simple RNN um and so uh back in 2011 we got some pretty decent results of showing that you could use this as a sentence paa that worked pretty well but beyond that that the representations um we calculated for sentences and phrases were good enough representations that you would use it
for tasks like sentence classification sentiment analysis and it works reasonably well um it only works it only worked reasonably well um because if you start thinking about it further you know there sort of wor strong limitations of having this single W Matrix that's used at all points to combine things that that if you sort of have that architecture you sort of can't have different forms of interaction between the different words you're s just uniformly Computing things and that sort
of stands in distinction to the fact that different kinds of things in natural language seem kind of different you have um different properties with verbs and their objects versus an adjective modifying a noun just in terms what the roles of the different words were so we started um to see limitations of this architecture and so in following years um we started exploring other ways to build tree recursive neural networks which had more flexibility as to how things were combined together and I'm
not going to show you all the details um of all of that but I will show you um one more um model that we use for building tree recursive newal networks and that was used in sort of some of our sentiment analysis work called the recursive newal tensor Network um it wasn't actually the final net version that we did after that we sort of started taking lstm ideas and extending those to the tree structured case and we worked on tree lsdm but I'm not going to show that this year um but the idea of
recursive newal tensor networks is you know when pairs of words or phrases combined together in linguistic semantics terms depending on the pairs of words they modify each other in different ways so if you have an adjective and a noun like um a red ball sort of red is giving attributes of the noun whereas if you have something like a verb in object um like kick the ball you've got a very different role for the object as the right hand side versus the red ball it's sort of the opposite way
around so we want to have more flexibility in the way we can calculate meanings of phrases depending on what's in it and the way we came up with doing that is to come up with what's we call this neural tensil layer and so the idea in the neural tensil layer is that we have had um the representations of um the the child um words or phrases and so rather than sort of directly putting rather than directly concatenating them and then um putting it through a sort of a linear transformation like a regular new
network layer instead what we could do is that we could learn um in between matrices and if we put several of those together we're then getting a three-dimensional tensor and we could multiply a vector um by a tenser time a vector and then we'll end up getting out um vectors for each one we'll have multiple such vectors okay and the the place that we applied this model is for this task of sentiment analysis so let me just tell you a little bit more of what we did here and this is sort of in fact going
backwards to the Stanford sentiment Tree Bank um that was already used in the Yim work so the goal of sentiment analysis is to see whether a piece of text is positive negative or neutral um so a lot of the time doing sentiment analysis is pretty easy um you know in the 2010s and probably even today you know quite a few people's sentiment analysis systems are essentially just um keyword matching right if you see great marvelous wonderful positive sentiment if you see something of poor bad negative sentiment
um and so lots of the time you can sort of effectively do a kind of dictionary matching and get pretty good sentiment especially on longer documents but you know on the other hand people use language in lots of interesting ways and it's not always that easy so if you look at something like movie reviews such as the Snippets you get on Rotten Tomatoes um you get Snippets like this in Rotten Tomatoes with this cast and this subject matter the movie should have been funnier and more entertaining and if you
just think of it as okay we're doing dictionary matching there's the word entertaining that's definitely positive um and funnier that's positive so there are two positive words so this should be a positive review but of course it's not a positive review this is a negative review um because it's saying um well I'm just reading it out again with this cast and subject matter the movie should have been funnier and more entertaining right so the compositional structure of
human language goes together to mean that these um because it's buried under should have been the funnier and entertaining are actually lacking and so it's a negative review and so these were the kind of examples that we were interested in and saying could we sort of actually understand the structure of sentences more and do a better job at sentiment analysis and so up until this time um people are just sort of had pieces of text and a classification Judgment of positive and negative so we decided we're going to do
more than that and come up with the Stanford sentiment Tree Bank where what we did was passed up a whole lot of sentences almost 12,000 of them and then what we are going to do is put sentiment judgments on every linguistic phrase of the sentence so for something like this example you know with this cast is a phrase no sentiments so that just be neutral um entertaining is a phrase a one-word phrase its sentiment is positive um um you know funnier and more entertaining that's a phrase very positive um but then by the
time we get embedded under should have been funnier and more entertaining that's a bigger phrase its sentiment is now negative and the movie should have been funnier and more entertaining that's an even bigger phrase it's negative and so we were um passing up trees like that and these examples are very small I'll show you a big examples later but you can sort of just see that in the trees there are blue nodes and orange nodes corresponding to positive and negative sentiment reflecting units
at the different sizes and so the interesting thing is then this gave us a richer annotated data set because it's not only sort of whole sentences or whole articles that were annotated for sentiment we had annotations for different phrases and simply the fact that you were annotating phrases meant that you could learn more from the examples so even if you're using something very simple like a naive based classifier because there an ations on Words and smaller phrases you could learn a bit more about which were
positive and which were negative and so that was the first result that we could um people a baseline method of a byr Nave Bas classifier which is a very common sentiment classifier that if you just trained with sentiment classifiers you got 79% on this data set if you trained with um if you trained using every node of the tree Bank um you got 83% so you got a 4% lift and so um that was kind of good um these other two lines show two of our early Tre tree rnns and the negative part of the result is they weren't really better than a
bite gram um naive Bas classifier they were better than a unigram naive Bas classifier but a lot of sort of the extra information that you want to capture for sentiment analysis you can get from byrams because that's can already tell you sort of not good um somewhat interesting and things like that um but then so the other Hope was to have a more powerful model and so that then led into use of this recursive newal tensor Network which allowed sort of the mediated multiplicative interactions between word or phrase
vectors um and so we built that and so then here are the results of that model that's shown in red um so by having our recursive newal tensor Network we were able to build um a somewhat better newal Network that performed at least reasonably better than a byr naive Bas model rate that we were getting sort of about 22% better than a by byr NA Bas model so that was progress but I think perhaps the more interesting thing isn't sort of the aggregate results but the fact that because we were building up
this model the computed representations over a constituency tree that it actually made judgments of different parts of sentences and how they combined so um here's the movie review sentence there are slow and rep repetitive Parts but it has just enough space to keep it interesting um so I hope you'll agree with the Judgment that overall that's a positive statement about the movie um and so the um recurs of newor tens Network builds the tree structure over this sentence and it says you know slow and repetitive that's
negative there are slow um repetitive Parts it's all negative to hear but for the part over to the right interesting um spice they're both positive and spice to keep it interesting that's positive it has just enough spice to keep it interesting positive and it correctly predicts that when you put these two halves of these sentences together um the overall judgment is that this remains um a positive review and it gives a positive judgment overall so that was kind of cool um and in particular um the fact that we were
building these phrase judgments um meant that it seemed like we could actually do a better job of sentence understanding in the way that sort of any linguist doing linguistic semantics would like to see sentence understanding so one of the things that newal networks when looking at language have often been faltered for and are still faled for to this day using Transformer models is you often find the result that um new network models just don't pay attention to negation that you can be um having some
sentence and you can compare the sentence of um you know a lot of students are studying for their final exams versus a lot of students aren't studying for their final exams and the negation just gets lost that it doesn't produce um the differences and representation and meaning that you'd like it to um so somewhat interestingly um with this model it seemed like because we were modeling the the cursive building up of sentence structure that we actually um could do interesting things with um modeling
negation right so in particular um that um what You' the results that you'd like to get is if you have something like it's just incredibly dull so dull is a very negative word um incredible is a positive word by itself but when you're sort of saying incredibly dull it's definitely still negative um and this um uh our recursive newor tensor network is um correctly modeling um it's just incredibly dull is very negative despite incredible being a sort of positive word so um you know actually in this um model
um there was five way classification so there was very negative somewhat negative neutral somewhat positive very positive um so there's sort of some bouncing around as to whether it's giving the classification very negative versus somewhat negative I can't really explain why in the middle it goes to somewhat negative and then goes back to very negative but that's the results that came out of the the network and at any rate if it all stays negative the fact that incredible by itself
incredibly is a positive word it's seen in the modif modification of dull as that keeps it negative but on the other hand if you put a negation in here it's definitely not Dull um well then what happens now interestingly the word not by itself is a negative word that if you just sort of do the raw statistics of it um not occurs much more often in negative sentiment sentences than it does in positive sentiment sentences so you know if you want to be a more positive person use negation less um so not by itself as
negative but if you then combine it together not Dull or in this case definitely not Dull um well not Dull is you have two negations so that they cancel each other out and you get something that's positive and so it's definitely not Dull comes out as a positive sentence and so the interesting result here is that um if you um compare what happens between you know if you have negated positive sentences so you know it's definitely not good various models can model that correctly because not is
a negative word and so therefore it weakens the positivity of the positive word and so putting a knot in front of a positive into a positive sentence makes it less positive and even a not very well but even a naive Bas model can do that because not by itself is seen as a negative word but the hard case is what happens if you negate a negative sentence well the result that you should get is it becomes more positive and neither a byr naive based model or our earlier attempts at recursive models can capture
that whereas this RNN structure was able to correctly modify capture this sort of semantic modification um structure and say hey that's made the sentence much more positive um so that was a cool result and to some extent you know this result I think still isn't captured as well by any of the um current Transformer models even though they have many other advantages and are much better than a tree recursive neural network um so I mean yeah so just to say a couple um this is basically the end um
to just say a couple of final remarks about these tree recursive new networks um you know the reason that they became uncompetitive is because they just didn't allow the kind of um associations and information flow that you have in a Transformer right that these these models had a strictly context free backbone and the only information flow was Tre structured following the context free backbone um whereas in the Transformer you've got this tension function where in every position you're looking at every other
position and so you can have much more general information flow and in general that is just good and Transformers are much more powerful but you know on the other hand to the extent that you actually want to model the sort of semantics of human language carefully is to sort of what modifies what and how does negation or quantifiers in a sentence behave in some sense these models were more right and so one of the things I'm still kind of interested in is are there any opportunities um to combine together some of the benefits of
both of these ways of thinking and have something that's a bit more tree structured while still more flexible like a Transformer okay that's it for today thanks a lot